so my name is Heather Miller I'm I
recently became a professor at CMU I
just started like four weeks ago so very
thank you thank you I'm barely a
professor Lee a professor there prior to
that I was the executive director of
this thing called the Scala Center for a
couple of years and I was also at
Northeastern University in Boston as a
faculty member there so I kind of for
the last several years I've sort of
spent time living both in industry land
a little bit in the sense that you know
I was working on this this open source
foundation and then trying to help it
grow and help help you know hire
engineers to do things that we need to
do for the scallop programming language
and then at the same time I was off
trying to do research and teach so I
kind of I'm kind of weird because I not
sure how to identify a my mine academic
probably but I you know I'm a little bit
more interested in what people actually
do so today I'm going to talk about
really it's it's mostly it's mostly
gonna be research because I think it can
be inspirational and I mean I you know I
guess I wouldn't be an academic if I
didn't love research but you know
counter to maybe what most people think
or the way most people see research I
actually think that it's extremely
animated it's just you know maybe
weirdly animated it doesn't look like it
from the outside in fact I think a lot
of the time this is how people view
research it's just like a bunch of PDFs
and somebody hiding in a cave reading
them and information is very hard to
obtain that's in these things and also
they're behind payables and oh my god
however you know yeah I don't I actually
actually think that research is a little
bit more dynamic and I think that this
view of okay you know an academic is
somebody hiding in a cave writing you
know complicated you know Matthew things
in PDF form making contrived
motivational statements about you know
real world problems that lack real world
context like I don't think that's
actually true in fact I think that
research is actually more like this
where it's a bunch of I mean
it evolves very weirdly slowly you've
got a bunch of people kind of chasing
some strange goal that nobody else can
understand until afterwards right we get
it later often and these are multi-year
sort of very long animated debates
actually where you have people making
points via these weird PDFs and arguing
always that this way or is it that way
and I think it's actually you know if
you can zoom out a little bit and and
sort of you know look at how these these
research papers kind of connect and then
sort of provide a dialogue about you
know what event you know some sort of
dialogue you know I think I think
actually research can be very exciting
even though it seems not exciting and so
uh you know last year actually gave a
talk at papers that the papers we love
conference and I kind of gave a
retrospective over the last like 30
years of distributed programming
languages and that was actually really
easy to try and give like a quick sort
well you know a fun hilarious little
tour of because you know a lot of these
topics were rather settled for example
Argos which was a really cool
programming language never caught on in
practice but we all got promises from
Argos so that's pretty cool right so
these things were largely resolved and
it was kind of easy to tell this story
over the course of you know 50 minutes
or something that I had you know because
you had like 30 years and this talk I
kind of wanted to do something similar
but I wanted to do it you know
more recently so rather than give you
know a retrospective of stuff that's
largely passed I figured what would be
the most useful for everybody in this
room would be if you're interested in
distributed programming what the heck is
going on like what you know what what
are people doing how is it going to help
and how do these things kind of relate
to one another so really you know I what
I want to give you in this talk is
actually context I want to give you a
really like a whirlwind tour kind of of
the last ten or so years of research
relating to programming language support
a compiler support for distributed
programming and at this point I'm going
to point out that
you know this is this kind of maybe this
is my personal sort of interest and so
things end up going in this direction a
little bit when I talk about language
support for distributed systems I'm I'm
really meaning ways that the compiler or
the programming language can help you
build a distributed application so I'm
not really interested in this talk to
talk about things like you know
verifying things or model checking or
things like that I'm actually interested
more in like languages compilers so it's
gonna be a little bit more the focus
today and I mean okay this is
you know there's absolutely actually
like you know there's the AXYZ mean
nothing here but let's just let's have
some intuition for a second if I could
visually depict all of the various
research projects in this distributed
programming space over the last you know
X years turns out that weird clusters
appear around certain topics I mean
maybe not weird it makes sense to me why
these exist but I mean you know
obviously this is not an exhaustive list
but there in the last few years there's
been a bunch of of a renewed interest in
looking at programming models and how
they relate to consistency and
consistency models so how do you deal
with consistency from the perspective of
the programming language of the
programming model session types are I'm
gonna briefly talk about them in a few
minutes it's another another idea for
trying to make it easier to make sure
that protocols are correct distributive
protocols are correct and then there's a
very very very active space around sort
of static analysis and verification of
distributed algorithms and things like
that
and then there's oh then there's other
there's other work that doesn't quite
neatly fit into one of these nice
categories I'm gonna talk about a few of
those things but to get you know again
today because I'm really interested
programming languages and programming
models I'm gonna talk more about these
other things I'm not going to really
talk about static analysis and
verification however I have a really
detailed like list of references in case
you're interested where things are like
nicely categorized in case you want to
read about the verification efforts but
the first thing I'll talk about again
this is a whirlwind tour so I'm just
gonna give you a taste of what these
things what's going on nowadays and
these things like I said they're all
largely in the last few years
okay consistency and programming models
what do I mean well I mean you know a
programming model that can you know
we're interested in sort of in the
research world in a programming model
that can provide some kind of guarantee
about the consistency in a distributed
system and an example of what I mean by
that I'm this is an example or many
possible examples let's say you have a
replica of some object or some piece of
data and you know you want this is like
a shared piece of mutable data but you
have a local local copy of it and maybe
there's some other node somewhere
updating something related to this piece
of data and you want to have whatever
you know updates that other people are
making to that piece of data event you
know where you are
so what guarantees do I have about you
know what others see if I update that
piece of data or if somebody else
updates that piece of data what do they
what kind of you know what kind of
guarantees do I have about you know do
we see the same thing or when I updated
do you see the same thing that I wrote
so this is kind of what I mean can you
know conceptually and sort of the the
standard thing is that you know we you
know forget about distribute systems for
a moment we tend to assume sort of
strong consistency which is you know in
the sort of I'm on one machine I'm just
updating some data you know this you
know most of the time everybody can see
that that update right and you know this
notion of strong consistency carries
over to distributed systems where you
can ensure that you know there's a bunch
of synchronization in the system and
everybody sees the same thing right
and recently what's become interesting
to look at is you know this idea of weak
consistency people realize well okay I
mean not 100% of the time is it
important for this piece of data to be
for every whole system to be
synchronizing on some piece of data I
mean perhaps in the case of like a bank
account it would be good however if
we're talking about like a light counter
on Facebook it's not so important
perhaps that you know everything
synchronized right so this has gotten to
be popular at least recently but it's
actually really I mean you know
conceptually it's kind of simple to
imagine right like all right I'm gonna
you know whatever we will eventually I
will eventually see what he sees right
straightforward just to think about but
actually quite difficult to
ensure that actually happens in practice
there are many ways to ruin you know
this consistency when you know you allow
all kinds of things not to be like
locking and things to be you know done
out of order right so it's actually
difficult to obtain and this is kind of
why there's a bunch of research on this
topic in recent years and I mean you
know a lot of this actually comes out I
mean I think a lot of people have have
heard of this cap theorem thing it's one
of two impossibility results that gets a
lot of attention I'm not sure it
deserves all the attention that it gets
but the sort of intuition is kind of
important here and I don't know if
you've seen this before but there's this
this cute pyramid that people like to
draw up and they you know there's the
the hey pic to where on one end we have
consistency so that's Oh oops whoa how
did linearize ability jump that should
be down there
all right pretend that on this slide
that's their linear a good the
availability of wound advisor people
didn't make sense okay but so
consistency is essentially linearize
ability just don't worry about that for
now we kind of talked about what that
means availability is basically means
that every request that you know is
received by something that has not
failed you know must result in some kind
of response that's not an error itself
so you know and basically means that you
know something can give a result I mean
simply put and partition tolerance
basically means that you know it can
deal with some sort of issue in the
network some sort of something there's
delays in the network or messages might
be dropped for some reason and so these
are the three sort of variables right
and this this sort of cap theorem
basically basically says pick two and
what that has resulted in there's a lot
of attention sort of being focused on
one edge of that of that of that pyramid
where the what we picked was it was that
whoa
so yeah people like to to say okay I
pick
availability and partition tolerance for
example so you'll see lots of like AP
model or whatever but basically whoops
man I'm going forward and backwards
alright so there's a there's this piece
of work which I think probably a lot of
people have heard the acronym for by now
they're called CR DTS and from a high
level you can think of these things as
basically being replicated data
structures so these are things that you
can copy all over the network and make
local updates to it and then you can be
guaranteed that the you know everybody
will eventually seem the same eventually
see the same result like whenever
updates eventually stop so and what
we're training here so like I said this
is this ap thing because you know we get
availability and partition tolerance but
we're sort of sacrificing consistency we
have weak consistency right and this is
very popular I don't know if anybody's
heard of react but it's oh it's a data
stat it's a it's a data store that has
CR DT is built into it a bunch of other
popular frameworks in industry have also
had these things sort of put into them I
believe alcohol was kind of a nice a
nice sort of model and and it's gotten a
lot of attention and I showed just one
paper there's gonna be a bunch of other
papers and the sort of list of
references of you know you guys can look
at if you really want to later which you
know this goes and many other directions
trying to make these things more
efficient looking at all the different
kinds of data structures that satisfy
the properties of a CR DT you know
basically can I have some weird data
structure that is very specific for my
application I don't know have some kind
of you know have the list of properties
that are required for it to be a CR DT
and for there to be strong eventual
consistency guaranteed so this is kind
of a popular sort of area that has
gotten a lot of attention in recent
years and you know building on that on
the whole parallel I'm sorry on the
whole programming model front you've got
you know works like this one this is a
good friend of mine Chris Michael John
he is he a few years back with peter van
roy built a like a kind of a dsl or a
little programming language built on top
of these these data structures so rather
than just having these little data
structures you can actually maybe build
up more interesting programs with like
higher order functions and things
and compose things together so you have
kind of a nice functional language built
on top of these things so it's a sort of
one step on top of that CR DT work and
then at the same time you know people
ask again Chris is asking questions well
you know what about this this pyramid
this weird pyramid that that you know
can I why is everybody looking at kind
of one edge of it let's maybe you know
play around with different sorts of
space or different sorts of areas on
that on that pyramid and he he has you
know there's a cute little program model
he proposed which basically aims to
provide consistency and availability so
basically the idea just to quote
directly quote his paper so he's got
this program model that he proposed
called spry and it it wants to trade-off
availability inconsistency at varying
variants in the application code and he
provides a number of applications one of
them is a CDN but in the end you know
what what he's really giving to you as a
programmer like as in the programming
model is a way to bound staleness and
freshness via annotation so is a result
too stale you know or you know how fresh
do I need something to be so you know
this is sort of again playing around on
that distributed source or that
programming model space of this problem
that you know the the famous pic 2
problem and there's a bunch of other
cool pieces of work that have also come
out sort of you know saying well fine
these programming models are kind of
restrictive I don't know if I want
everything in my distributed system to
be you know weekly consistent and have
to deal with this eventual consistency
what if I what if I have a programming
model lets me do multiple things and
this actually came out of the
distributed systems community so if you
actually like dig around and the
research you're going to find that a lot
of this talk about programming models
for these underlying things they usually
are in the the programming languages
space but this came out of the
distributed systems community in 2015
and it's an abstraction called
correctable it relates to futures in
that you have these these kind of
callbacks that you can implement and
they are they basically provide
different each of the callbacks provide
just a different consistency
guarantees so I mean the really high
level sort of quick glance of this of
the system is that you know as you have
something that's like a future and you
can choose the consistency guarantees
that you need so there are these three
api's so obviously the first to either
allow strong or weak consistency and for
whatever operation you pass to it and
basically they let you kind of make a
decision in the in the in the in the
programming model about you know when
you need strong and to see or when you
need weak consistency you can do this at
the level of like the application code
and something is a little bit more
complicated that's in the paper you can
actually specify you know like you know
you can kind of make like a spectrum of
of how strong or weak you want it to be
with this other this other method I
encourage you to have a look at the
paper form or and there's another piece
of work that just came out this year
actually it was in P L di in June and
this is basically another programming
model that lets you sort of choose
different consistency models at the
level of the programmer right and then
this is different from the last one and
that instead what you're doing is you
can sort of mix consistency models by
you you can like there are different
remote storage sites that you can have
associated with different consistency
models basically and this is actually
like a programming language or a DSL I
believe which does sort of extra type
checking and it does sort of information
flow based type checking to sort of
guarantee that you're not mixing things
in the wrong way so that you know you
don't you don't you know you don't you
don't mix the you know the wrong
consents these models together in some
subsequent operation later and so this
is just a quick glance I have again I'm
going to show you in a few minutes some
more you know just like a laundry list
of of more papers that you could look at
if you're ever interested in looking any
deeper than what I've just showed you
but sort of the high-level summary of
this is that you know when we realized
that hey sometimes our applications can
tolerate weak consistency it got to be
popular to say hey
let's play around with this let's have
data structures or other sort of
programming models that let us sort of
trade-off on consistency and then people
started asking other questions well can
we have multiple models of consistency
in the same programming model or even
better like can we have different things
like can we just focus on availability
instead I mean I don't care too much
about consistency I mean I don't know
why you would not care but whatever some
people I don't know but you know it's an
interesting question right like what
other sort of spaces on the in this
little funny triangle can we explore and
this has sort of been something that's
been popular and probably lost you know
just exploring the different the
different mixing the models and and the
different sorts of mixture and the
different sorts of points in this design
space and this has only been in like the
last four or five years that people have
been even playing around with this in
mass I guess there's a lot of people a
lot of work going on in this space
another thing which so my research is
actually more related to this
consistency stuff I'm more interested in
that something else that's very popular
people a lot of people are very
interested in in the last few years is
this idea of session types so I don't
know you might have heard the you know
it's a buzzword I'm gonna give you a
really again some intuition about what
these things are but you know what you
can think of at a high level is the
session types provide a way to type
communication protocols so you can have
you know you can basically make the
assumption that if your program type
checks then it's guaranteed to follow
the defined communication protocol and I
mean you know to me like what that means
is I don't have random machines hanging
waiting for something that you know
should have gone to some I don't know
like there's something messed up where
you got some partial results you messed
up the implementation of this protocol
and you know three three machines are
timing out somewhere because the
communication protocol is screwed up
basically you you completely remove that
possibility from happening so this is
wonderful right because I can't tell you
how many how much how many headaches or
you know I have I have I have dealt with
trying to deal with some messed up
communication protocol or which I've
heard or
at about so this is a really wonderful
guarantee to be able to sort of aspire
to you right and what's also interesting
to note is there are also many types
because this is a very busy space in
recent years so you know you might if
you start googling this to learn more
you're gonna notice that there's
something called binary accession types
and multi-party session types and that
basically means you know can I you know
does this this this typing of this you
know between you know nodes is it
between two nodes or more than two notes
basically so binary is basically you
know between two parties and multi-party
it can be more and then there also
exists static and dynamic variants so
there exists I mean as you can imagine
you know you have a statically typed
language you would probably end up with
a static session types system and there
exists also session typing sort of
implementations and realizations for
languages like Python so there's this
static dynamic divergence there and I
basically tried to find because I don't
work on this myself I tried to find a
good very simple example that I could
very quickly provide and I have to give
props to Simon Fowler who works on
session types and specifically in a
programming language called links he has
a really cute example that I liked a lot
and I recommend reading reading his
introduction if you're interested in
session types so basically what you have
is kind of like a type definition on the
client and on the server side and here
we are looking at the client side you
have this funny plus symbol thingy here
and what that basically means is that
you know you have two two branches that
you can choose between on the one hand
you have the oh sorry I should have
pointed out I just started talking about
the example this is an example
implementation of SMTP sorry
so the SMTP client side we have these
two branches the e hlo
branch where you have this is basically
just a bunch of pieces of information
that you want to have have sent so in
this case you have the client sending
with the bank symbol the basically the
domain
the address that a message should be
sent from the address that you're
sending to and then the actual message
that you're trying to send and then
basically the protocol would repeat at
that point and the other branches stop
basically quit and the protocol yeah so
yeah the bank symbol is this end and
these are the things that you're sending
and then basically you you repeat and
quit
protocols over on the server side it's
basically a complete dual of this so
instead of the instead of the little
plus operator we have this this end
symbol which is basically a dual of the
plus instead of instead of selecting
you're offering a choice between the
following branches on the server side
and it's the same sort of same it's
exactly the same thing as before and so
this is kind of the you know the high
level sort of like definition of the
client the server in this application
and this would be the implementation of
the client doesn't really matter so much
you know the details except all of the
you know oh you should just note that
all of the C's here I got like VAR c 1
VAR c 2 VAR c 3 everything is returning
a new channel and point upon being bound
on each cent so that's why you see all
these things but you know here we are
using like selecting the CHL oh oh we're
doing all of our sins when we're done
we're quitting basically and what the
compiler does in this case is it just
make sure it sort of you know well
there's a whole there's a whole very
interesting type system behind this but
basically if this type checks and you're
guaranteed that sort of this protocol
will be be correct and the cool thing is
you know there's I actually showed you a
code example most of the time when you
read about this stuff it's it's very
formal it's mostly you know it's it's
mostly actually the type systems that
you that you find when you pick up an
academic paper but the cool thing to
note is that there are many
implementations of these things in in
you know in the wild ones that you might
have heard of
so rust has one so these are the names
of the packages in case you care about
googling any of these languages so in
rust so there's a package called session
types and Scala there's one called L
chance
but we have them also in languages like
Erlang at Haskell Python there's several
Java ones there's a well-known
implementation called scribble and it's
also important to note that remember I
said some of these are multi-party some
of these are binary so the I think rusts
and scholars and Haskell's are binary
the rest are multi-party but you know
details it's the important thing to walk
away with is basically that you know
these things are actually implemented
they're not just a cute little you know
thought exercise and actually one thing
that's really cool about AI CFP being
co-located with with with Strange Loop
is that the people who work on these are
here actually I mean at least I saw them
yesterday maybe they're still here today
so I mean you know if you see one of
these guys they're really interested in
these things you know tell them right
there I'm sure they're very excited to
know that people are interested in using
these things and again I have to say if
you're if you want to learn more about
them Somnath dollars article is really
cool I encourage you to have a look so
those are the two kind of clusters that
I wanted to mention about you know all
this activity going on right so you have
people worrying about consistency and
how to like reason about it and you've
got people worrying about you know how
to type these communication protocols
and there's a lot of activity around
those things but there's a bunch of
other cool things that don't fit into
those categories that are potentially
interesting or useful to practice one
that I I've read about recently it's
called wit it's a contract system for
micro services that's cool right and I'm
really excited about this because I
think that the academic community hasn't
given enough attention to these things I
mean it's I mean everybody in this
audience is probably like oh god don't
say the micro service word because you
know it's all over the place right and
everybody's using them and building them
with them and you know okay everybody is
doing this but we're not you know maybe
with our type systems and things we're
not really I don't know there's not that
much that we're we're doing to try and
help you on the academic front so I'm
really excited about this WIPP work
which basically I mean to give you a
quick taste it you know it it what makes
it stand apart from other academic works
is the fact that
you know it takes sort of design
decisions and sort of has goals that are
really embracing this whole issue or
issue a situation whatever you want to
call it they're being umpteen zillion
micro services that you have to manage
and deal with so the the sort of design
of this thing was based on the idea that
it would always have to operate under
some sort of partial deployment it would
be transparent and wouldn't mess with
your communication it would be language
agnostic so if you're implementing all
of your services in different languages
like it's not getting in your way and
finally that there should be some sort
of lose coupling between that and sort
of thrift or some other you know wire
protocol that that you might be
interested in using that's awesome right
and so but it's what it does is a you
know it so you know it basically
guarantees that you end up using
services correctly I guess it's like
having almost like a dynamic type in
between them which is neat another thing
that I want to mention exists I don't
know much about yet I'm gonna go bother
these people soon
you should also you should also follow
this it looks interesting this is a
programming language that folks from the
scallop community have started building
recently and it's a it's a Haskell like
language which where you can move
computation around and these
computations that are they're kind of
just you know interpreted on you know
our Turing knows which is cool and also
potentially scary so I would love to
learn more about this and they have an
unconference session I think it's
tonight so if you actually have more
questions you can go go see it but this
is something that's really cool because
it's kind of in the space of research
just not in the sort of mainstream one
of the main threads of research but it's
it's it's interesting and it's happening
right now another thing that's very neat
which reminds me a lot of this language
called Lynda sometimes is a language
that toni Garrn know toni Garrn ik jones
designed called syndicate and what's
really interesting about this language
is that it has this notion of data
spaces which is like a tuple space a
little bit but a little nicer and I mean
you know just you should know about this
and you know maybe read one of the
tutorials or something that he think
he's written a tutorial or something or
case reads thesis he writes beautifully
and one other thing that I'd like to
mention before I start kind of winding
down is there's a piece of work
which kind of predates a lot of this fad
which I found pretty interesting when I
was doing my PhD it's called it's a
programming language called ml5 which
tries to reason about locations and
whatnot in the type system and you know
they have ideas like mobile closures and
things like this and it's a of course
ml5 it's a variant of ml and you know
it's it's it's ahead of its time I think
and this is something that we did
recently it's a programming model it's
not even a language of any kind it's
basically like a actually spoke about
this a couple of years ago it's strange
loop it's a you can think of it as like
a distributed sort of immutable data
structure where everything is you're
applying functions to other locations in
the network it kind of turns the idea of
message passing like backwards and so
that's weird because as it into any
category either and sort of whoops we
thought I wanted to kind of give a
bird's-eye view of some of the things
that at least you know I work in this
space and some of the things that I
think are interesting that we're
beginning to work on now that I'm like
four and a half weeks or something into
my my job so one thing that's pretty
neat that actually we started with Chris
McHale johnsy Shawn Makani and Peter
Alvaro was this kind of tongue-in-cheek
paper that was rejected in flames it was
a it was a workshop paper that so I mean
it was must've been really angering if
it was a workshop ever that was rejected
in flames basically it's a you know the
title is maybe also piss people off
verifying interfaces between container
based components and then in tiny
letters or a type system by any other
name so yeah we're in this paper we were
proposing this idea of of actually
trying to provide types to sort of check
configurations between components and
this is this is something that Albert
Chang and I have been recently talking
about a lot and I think we're going to
get going on
very soon and the idea is that you know
maybe we can come up with a type system
and then sort of not have it really like
a language that you have to deal with in
your in your actual you know
implementation of anything but it could
be something that you could be deploying
as part of your CI to make sure that
certain components that you know are in
your system adhere to some invariant
that some other component or some other
service has so that you know when you
when you deploy something in breaks of
invariants or some other team service
that you know you have no idea what
their invariants are at least you can
catch this in the CI rather than having
to sort of be woken up in the middle of
the night to figure out what the heck
happened so this is something that we're
getting started on and then another
project that we've been working on a
little bit or has been working on for a
little while now this with my student
Kevin Clancy is actually a type system
to ensure that functions are monotone
which sounds like gibberish Mandy but
what that is is so if you kind of we
roll back to the CRI DT stuff it turns
out that you can really easily screw
those things up if you're implementing
them yourself you can sort of sort of
you know violate some of the invariants
that have to hold in order to ensure
that this sort of eventual consistency
thing happens and one of those sort of
properties that always has to hold is
that sort of operations on these things
are monotone like for some definition of
monotone and wouldn't it be cool if you
know maybe we could have something check
that what you did is actually monotone
when people are implementing their own
CRT T's so that's the idea of that work
and that's going to be that's something
that is basically completely Greek for
now and one day hopefully we hope we can
actually implement it in the system that
would be able to be used by people but
you know it's it's kind of also on the I
pointed out it's kind of also on the
fringe like it's not the the thing that
everybody else is doing we're kind of
like on the edge doing weird stuff and
so that's kind of the stuff that we're
working on recently and I also want to
call out you know I own a bunch of a
bunch of areas I quickly flashed up a
bunch of papers I think that's very I
don't know inhumane I like to show faces
so there are a number of people working
in this space actually know some of them
don't know others I follow their work
but if you're actually if you think any
of this stuff is inter
thing you know the the best thing to do
is actually to you know take note of
some of these folks and follow their
work because these are the people who
are usually year after year kind of
publishing interesting results in this
space and you know I also want to point
out that I have a ridiculous number of
references which you know offline when
you if you're interested if you're
interested in learning more about any of
these things you can use make this like
a a choose drew an adventure story or
she can like dig down one of these
random paths that I've presented before
you and you'll you'll see so there's a
few a few pages of this I don't know if
you follow any of the academic sort of
you know conferences this is where so in
academia at least in computer science
the main results are presented usually
in conferences and I see AP it was one
of them there's like four big ones every
year and this was one of the big ones
and it was co-located with Angelou so
you'll see there was actually a paper
that was presented the other day about
fault-tolerant functional reactive
programming which was a functional / was
pretty cool but you know PL di you saw
poeple a coupe these are all acronyms
but they're also academic conferences
where they're publishing usually work
related to programming models and
programming languages and there's
actually so I mentioned earlier that
there's a lot of this work happening
mostly in the programming languages
space so I have many pages of references
just in the last few years of sort of
the programming languages community I
kind of stopped in in in 2006 I think
because started getting more sparse by
then but that just shows you in the last
10 12 years really there's been like a
great uptick and I'm sort of happy that
that's happening because you know as we
are dealing with more things like
micro-services appearing and then you
know they're wonderful for some reasons
and awful for other reasons you know I'm
glad that the academic community is
taking a look at things like this and
there's a number of other references
which I'm going to I'm going to leave
for you several famous references things
like note on distributed computing and
the fallacies of
tributed commuting things that you know
if you're interested again in
distributed systems or distributed
computing you should be aware of these
things and I'm posting these with my
slides up at this link right after right
after the talk and with that I'm
actually just about oh a couple minutes
I still have couple minutes I'm happy to
answer questions
so questions are they they still sleet
oh I can't actually yeah sorry man
or do I do it alright then I can choose
what I want to answer not nobody can
choose for me haha its SL 218 right yep
got it are you guys tired I don't know
yep I got it
hooray oh cool alright alright I got two
questions awesome so yarn Minsky asks
what do you think about the relationship
between mix consistency models for
distributed systems and work on memory
models for multi-core systems that's a
good question
so I don't know I think I think that
people often look at distributed
anything in the distributed space as
sort of an extension of concurrent
whatever like choose choose a choose a
topic and then they try to extend the
concurrent case to the distributed case
and I think that I mean personally I
just think that there's a number of
things that you know come up like
latency and other things that it would
be nice if there was some way to
actually reason about that which I don't
see happening when you're thinking about
different memory models for multi-core
systems and all I mean you know so I
guess the answer to my question is that
you know I think that there are
additional concerns which you know often
they'll pop up in that scenario so I
think it requires sort of different
attention given to it this is like very
lonely you guys I don't know about this
this is this asking questions via via
app is there a research at the
intersection of political science and CS
relating to motion storage of data and
algorithms and impacts on distributed
systems actually I have no idea I don't
know I don't I
intersection of political science since
yes I don't know anything about
political science so you're asking the
wrong person
sorry and so I've questioned asking what
what is what I mean by monotone in terms
of CR D T's so you can okay so this can
actually become an involved definition
but the simple way to think of it is
that you've got something that's always
increasing like an operation that's
always causing some sort of increase in
one case you it could be just always
increasing the size of the data
structure and like not destroying it for
example so this is what I mean by like a
monotonic function it's kind of you know
increase in general this idea of
increasing it for some definition of
what am i increasing
[Music]
yeah Wow Dave D asks is there any
overlap and research between session
types and Ciardi T's that's a good
question I you know I feel like I'm a
scatterbrain with like his umpteen
zillion papers that I try to keep track
of and just sort of like running through
what I'm aware of I know specific paper
comes up where like set I mean I don't
for I mean recession type sincerity T's
try to to do anything together that I'm
aware of
I mean that doesn't mean they don't
exist it's just that I have not tripped
over this one okay another question by
NOAA have you done any work with Erlang
elixir and OTP what's your general
opinion on the actor model so I come
from Scotland man I like I like my diet
we have actors right although I have to
point out that you know so the actor
model and skala was borrowed from from
Erlang and we have this wonderful like
any to unit type or not to whatever
actors are a partial function from any
to unit which is if you like types it's
a very useless type so so I have to say
that you know every time I start trying
to use the actor model in Scala I'm
having a great time loving it loving it
loving it and then the sort of lack of
typing sort of drives me a little bit
nuts and I don't I mean other than like
playing around building stupid little
example applications in Erlang I've
really been firmly in Scotland and then
comparing sort of aspects of Erlang to
Scala but never actually working in
Erlang to answer your question but you
know I am I love the actor model for the
record although yes I mean I'm starting
to enjoy Roland Kunz
typed actors
and and akka a lot more lately oh no
it's hard to see now things are out of
order oh my god no wait I have one more
okay are you trying to kick me off fine
okay one more from John Hughes and then
I'll let you escape all right
so John use asks do you think low very
low power settings like sensor networks
that only communicate occasionally can
use the same abstractions that's a very
good question actually because this is
something that I think whenever you
start talking about like edge and blah
blah people start getting like they trip
over it a lot you know they they think
immediately like a sensor network or
something that's power constrained and
actually a lot of these things that I
care about I'm assuming that they're not
power constrained so in the case of like
the CRT T's I'm assuming that you got
you can run something on it which has
like a garbage collector right and that
you know you don't have to worry about
the thing wasting cycles yet so at the
moment I'm not I'm not really focused on
sort of these these you know edge you're
sort of smallish devices sort of being
powered power constraint I'm more
interested in things like mobile phones
and with that I think I'm over time so I
will let you guys go thank you for thank
you for the very animated question
session
[Applause]